>>> PRESIDENT BIDEN TODAY
ANNOUNCED A FULL BAN ON RUSSIAN
NATURAL GAS, COAL IMPORT TO THE
UNITED STATES.
HE SAID HE HOPES THIS WILL DEAL
ANOTHER POWERFUL BLOW TO PUTIN'S
WAR MACHINE.
JOINING TO US DISCUSS,
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR CHRIS MURPHY
OF CONNECTICUT WHO SERVES ON THE
SENATE FOREIGN RELATIONS
COMMITTEE AND HEARD PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY.
HOW BIG OF AN IMPACT WILL THIS
MAKE, ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT THIS
IS A UNILATERAL MOVE MADE
INDEPENDENT OF EUROPEAN ALLIES,
THOUGH I'M SURE BIDEN TRIED TO
GET THEM ON BOARD.
>> THIS IS NOT A SYMBOLIC MOVE
BUT WITHOUT RUSSIA -- EXCUSE ME,
WITHOUT EUROPE, THE IMPACT OF
REMOVING OIL FROM IMPORT TO THE
UNITED STATES IS PROBABLY
LIMITED.
LISTEN, I THINK THERE'S A MORAL
IMPERATIVE FOR THE UNITED STATES
TO NOT SEND MONEY TO FUND
PUTIN'S WAR.
BUT WE ARE A VERY SMALL SHARE OF
RUSSIA'S EXPORTS.
SO DOING THIS WITHOUT EUROPE, I
DON'T THINK IS NECESSARILY GOING
TO FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE PUTIN'S
CALCULUS.
IT IS ULTIMATELY GOING TO BE THE
ACCUMULATION.
IMPACT OF ALL THE ECONOMIC
SANCTIONS THAT MAY EVENTUALLY
CAUSE PUTIN TO REALIZE, HE MAY
HAVE A CHOICE TO BE MADE BETWEEN
PERPETUATING THIS WAR IN
UKRAINIAN AND KEEPING A HOLD ON
POWER.
SO I'M GLAD THE PRESIDENT WENT
AHEAD WITH IT.
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE SURE
THERE'S NOT TOO BIG OF AN IMPACT
ON AMERICAN CONSUMERS.
WITHOUT EUROPE, THE MACK ON
PUTIN REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
>> AS YOU KNOW, IT IS ONLY A
SMALL SLICE OF U.S. ENERGY
NEEDS.
JUST 8% IN 2021.
IN THE SECOND HALF OF FEBRUARY,
THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY
REPORTED THAT IMPORTS DROPPED TO
ZERO AS U.S. COMPANIES CUT TIES
WITH RUSSIA.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT AMERICAN
COMPANIES WERE ALREADY DOING
THIS, WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT THIS
BAN?
WAS IT NECESSARY?
OR WAS THE FREE MARKET ALREADY
DOING IT?
>> AS THE UNITED STATES ECONOMY
CONTINUES TO REV UP, THERE WAS
CERTAINLY GOING TO BE AN
INCREASED DEMAND ON ENERGY
CONSUMPTION.
AND THUS, YOU ALWAYS HAVE THE
POSSIBLE OF PRIVATE COMPANIES
BRINGING IN RUSSIAN ENERGY.
I THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO HAVE
THIS POLICY ON THE BOOKS.
I JUST DON'T KNOW THAT WE SHOULD
OVERHYPE ITS IMPACT.
ULTIMATELY, THE BROADER
SANCTIONS THAT WE'VE LEVIED ON
RUSSIAN BANKS AND NEWS OF ALL
THE PRIVATE COMPANIES FROM
STARBUCKS TO COCA-COLA TO
MASTERCARD PULLING OUT OF
RUSSIA.
THAT'S WHERE THE PRIMARY IMPACT
WILL BE.
BUT LET'S ADMIT, THE INSANITY OF
U.S. ECONOMY THAT CONTINUES TO
RUN ON OIL THAT IS PROVIDED TO
US BY DICTATORS.
THE REALITY IS IF WE'RE NOT
GETTING THIS FROM RUSSIA, WE'RE
LIKELY GOING TO BE IMPORTING
MORE FROM ANOTHER BRUTAL
DICTATOR, IN SAUDI ARABIA, FOR
INSTANCE, OR WE MAY HAVE TO GO
TO VENEZUELA.
WE SHOULD LEARN OUR LESSON HERE
AND BECOME ENERGY INDEPENDENT
AND CHOOSE TO INVEST IN CLEAN
DOMESTIC ENERGY SO WE NEVER HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN ONE DICTATOR
VERSUS ANOTHER.
>> REPUBLICANS SAY THE SAME
THING EXCEPT THEY'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT CLEAN ENERGY.
THEY'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT
AMERICAN FOSSIL FUELS FROM
LOUISIANA OR ANWR OR KEYSTONE.
YOU RAISE AN IMPORTANT POINT.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE MORAL
IMPERATIVE OF NOT FUNDING
PUTIN'S BARBARIC WAR AGAINST THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
BUT NOW WE'LL BE FUNDING MADURO
AND VENEZUELA?
OR THE MULLAHS IN IRAN?
THESE ARE ALSO GOVERNMENT THAT'S
ARE DOING THINGS THAT, THEY'LL
TAKE OUR MONEY AND USE IT TO DO
THINGS THAT ARE MORALLY RETHAT
YOU GO NANT.
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK MASSIVE
IMPORTS ARE COMING FROM IRAN ANY
TIME SOON.
LIKELY WE'LL NEED TO IMPORT MORE
FROM THE SAUDIS AND ON ANY GIVEN
DAY, THE BEHAVIOR OF THE SAUDI
REGIME RIVALS THAT OF THE
VENEZUELANS.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT DOMESTIC OIL
PRODUCTION, THERE IS NO
GUARANTEE THAT STAYS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WHEN WE PRODUCE OIL IN THE
UNITED STATES, THAT GOES TO THE
HIGHEST BIDDER.
SOMETIMES THAT'S HERE IN THE
U.S.
BUT OFTENTIMES, THAT OIL GETS
SENT TO CHINA.
IT GETS SENT TO EUROPE REFL
NEWABLE ENERGY STAYS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WHEN WE ARE PRODUCING ENERGY
FROM SOLAR PANELS OR WIND
TURBINE, THAT STAYS ON THE
AMERICAN GRID.
IF YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT KEEPING
AMERICAN ENERGY IN THE UNITED
STATES, YOU SHOULD BE INVEFLTING
IN RENEWABLES.
>> SO GAS PRICES ARE AT RECORD
HIGHS.
A LOT OF AMERICANS ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING TO BUY GAS FOR THEIR
CAR.
THIS MIGHT NOT AFFECT YOU OR ME.
BUT PEOPLE IN RURAL AMERICA WHO
TRAVEL LONG DISTANCES, PEOPLE
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
THIS REALLY MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
WHAT CAN THE ADMINISTRATION DO
TO HELP STRUGGLING AMERICANS?
POLLS INDICATE THAT PEOPLE
INCLUDING A NUMBER OF
REPUBLICANS ARE WILLING TO
SACRIFICE FOR THIS MORAL
IMPERATIVE.
WHAT MORE CAN BE DONE FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO REALLY CAN'T AFFORD
THIS?
>> I THINK YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
AND I'VE BEEN SAYING THIS FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL DAYS.
I FRANKLY DIDN'T WANT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO MOVE OUT TOO
QUICK WILL YOU ON THIS POLICY
WITHOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE
COULD BACKFILL THAT RUSSIAN OIL.
BECAUSE I DO THINK IT IS REALLY
EASY FOR THE POLITICAL ELITES IN
WASHINGTON TO TELL LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS THEY SHOULD PAY MORE
FOR A GALLON OF GASOLINE TO SAVE
UKRAINE.
THAT'S A LOT HARDER FOR PEOPLE
WHO DON'T HAVE THE EXTRA MONEY
IN WATERBURY, CONNECTICUT.
IN THE SHORT TERM, THAT PROBABLY
DOES MEAN WE'LL HAVE TO BRING IN
MORE OIL FROM PLACES LIKE SAUDI
ARABIA.
I'M INTERESTED IN A PROPOSAL
THAT SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
HERE TO TEMPORARILY SUSPEND THE
GAS TAX TO TRY TO DEFRAY THE
COST.
BUT AS LONG AS THIS WAR IS
HAPPENING IN UKRAINE, THE MARKET
IS